أغرب رئيس في التاريخ،
صاحب أغرب قوانين وعادات في التاريخ،
هو أقسى رجل مر في رئاسة كوريا الشمالية،
لا يمر عام إلا ويثير الجدل في العديد من السياسات والمواضيع،
لكن! ما لذي فعله كيم جونغ هذه المرة؟
.
.. قبل معرفة ذلك، نرجوا الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله....
رئيس كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ أون،
دخل التاريخ من أوسع أبوابه هذه المرة،
فما هو جديده؟...
قالت صحيفة بريطانية أنّ الزعيمَ الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون،
حقنَ نفسهُ بالذهب للعلاجِ من السرطان والبدانة والخرف.
نعم إنه كما سمعتم لقد حقن نفسه بالذهب! ..
أمتأكد أنت يا كيم من فعل هذا؟....
وأضافت الصحيفة ذاتها، أنّ عدداً من العلماء في كوريا الشمالية،
أصدروا مجموعة جديدة من العقاقير
يقولونَ أنّها أفضلُ من أيّ شيء آخر متاح في الدول الغربية،
لعلاج السرطان والبدانة والخرف.
ووفقاً للصحيفة، فإنّ الطبقة العليا فقط في كوريا الشمالية،
هي التي يمكنها الوصول إلى هذا النوع الجديد من الرعاية...
فهل هذه العقاقير لعلاج الخرف، أم أن كيم جونغ أصبح عجوزا خرف؟!!!!
لكن ربما هذا العلاج ليس جديدا أيضا،
فقد ذكرت الصحيفة البريطانية في تقريرها أيضا،
أن الفكرة لا تعتبر جنونية،
نظراً لأنه توجد نسخة من هذا العلاج متوافرة في بريطانيا،
مشيرة إلى أن حقن الذهب أو “مي وكريسين”
عبارة عن عقار مضاد للروماتيزم مصنوع من مركب يسمى أوروثيومالات الصوديوم،
هذا وطور العلماء في كوريا الشمالية أيضًا 50 علاجًا مضادًا للسرطان
مصنوعًا من نباتات محلية.
بينما أوضحت صحيفة كورية أن هذه العقاقير
تعالج الأمراض المزمنة، إضافة إلى السمنة والضعف،
وأنهم ينصحون الجميع بها؛ نظراً لأنها تخفف التعب الجسدي،
وتمنح الشخص نشاطًا بدنياً....
وقد أطل كيم جونغ في ظهور له، بفقدانه الكثير من الوزن،
ويتمتع بلياقة بدنية وجه مبتسم، مما يعطي
إشارات واضحة، لنجاح الترياق،،،
.... فإلى أي مدى يمكن لكيم جونغ الوصول،
وهل يزداد جنونه كلما كبر، أم أنه لم يصل لذلك بعد؟
وبحسب صحيفة “ذا صن” البريطانية، فإن الزعيم الكوري كيم جونج أون،
ونخبته يحقنون أنفسهم بالذهب، كعلاج من العديد من الأمراض.
.. يبدو أن كيم جونغ لا يخوض مغامراته لوحده بل يجر مسؤوليه معه،،،
لمتابعة مايفعله كيم جونغ من ظاهرة أو سياسة أو قانون أو عقاب جديد ،،،
ما عليكم إلا الاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات وسنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله